so let me ask about texas what's going
on in texas because this i mean this is
wow
this is uh interesting stuff and
interesting that the supreme court
already basically heard it i heard now
that the justice department biden's
department is going to sue texas and
what take it all the way to the supreme
court oh wait
we did that and the supreme court said
texas
you do you
uh so i'm wondering if this could
backfire though you know republicans
always seem to me
to be happier when they're out of office
because they just are so good at
bitching
and they just love to own the libs and
complain and when they get into office
and they get to enact some of their
ideas
they scare the out of people
and i think this is the you know
elections are one on fear
a lot of the time i mean that's how
trump got in you the fear of the
overreaching of the liberals and so
forth i'm wondering if this could really
help
i think governor abbott is helping gavin
newsom i think people are going to look
at that and go oh my god we don't want a
republican governor here in this state
if that's what a republican governor
might do
and
[Music]
you think that's possible
it is definitely possible you know in my
lifetime covering or in my career
covering politics so many people would
talk about this concept that if roe v
wade was ever overturned if women would
take to the streets and that would just
end everything and you'd have a
permanent democratic majority and
this has been slowly happening for a
very very long time especially at state
legislators people have been challenging
trying to get things to the court you
know what trump did to the judiciary
across the country had very very strong
lasting effects and i shouldn't just say
mitch mcconnell and trump you know
completely changing the judiciary with
justices who would
be in favor of things like what happened
in texas and i think it is extremely
dangerous i mean i can go into the
merits of that i don't know if that's
the debate you want to have but
and then particularly in texas where you
know they're trying to restrict voting
rights um but they're also forcing
sports teams to have the national anthem
at every single game in texas
while you're not allowed to do something
with your own body um it is it is
dangerous and really alarming for any
person not just a woman
the texas law is a short-lived sideshow
as soon as it's enforced by one of these
private attorney generals this citizen
sues another citizen it will i'm
confident be struck down summarily the
big show is coming this fall when there
will be oral arguments in the
mississippi case
where the court is being asked
explicitly to overturn roe v wade
and by june of 2022 in the midst of the
off-year elections there'll be an answer
to that
you